we are watching the red dead redemption
2 trailer time uh it's gonna be
worthwhile cool watching one more time
let's get into it yeah
listen to me
when the time comes you got
don't look back
this is over
alright so my first take away that
didn't look like super Western I mean
there are some spots but they like those
look like the Rockies right totally so I
would you steal the Bison to that we're
yelling like that kind of pathetic this
is sure what we talked about that we
kind of wanted right like force really
like wash wilderness cups against
restroom yeah so let's just go through
it again bring this up um yeah that was
a like all right we got rights again
this looks pretty lush compared to what
we were used to in the first red dead
duh same here oh I'm assuming the
Rockies so that's a do you think so this
X sorry that is a honey badger design ya
say so she's like right here it's like a
heron it looks like these don't these
don't look like animals are indigenous
to like the southwest or damn blue the
blue yeah look at the sky on that and if
you get to see something like that I'd
be so awesome that's mean it's implying
again hunting right here of course which
would be prospected that looked like a
Native American canoe so maybe like yeah
okay this looks like what canoe kayak I
think canoe base bar what's going on
going on here anything Cardinal okay
that would be nice no yeah there's
definite oh that snow capped mountains
like this looks like it's from the first
game like not not graphic but it looked
this area looks like it could be from
the first game I wonder like if there's
gonna be any overlap in this map with
the other one or I don't know it doesn't
look like the guy right here yeah it's
like it looks like the person rowing
looks like a Native American Indian with
a headband from this far away like the
long hair kind of but definitely canoe
some sort with a hat yeah like couldn't
you see it just to branch off what you
said Jake like can you can you imagine
like you know here's your original red
dead map and it's like let's just shift
north yeah yeah I'm just like the north
like as the game place in though like
bison or like the long lengthy original
this is a sick shot that's like we're
sure
back to this yeah yeah you can use space
burn I know I just want to watch the cab
okay I mean I don't doesn't look like
there's any groceries dry goods I mean
cuz tonic drugs looking at the
background like it looks like this is
kind of in a colder area like yeah near
the mountains at least that looks like
sort of a mountain but I mean that kind
of setting was in the first 12 i'm
curious what year this one yes I think
you're right that is very much a
northern colder environment coming later
yeah like thinking like had a hateful
eight kind of thing yeah it's like
around that like at the Badlands maybe
back to the general store shop like if
you imagine I know I was about to say
like maybe like their attire like what
how much clothing they're wearing would
like right would resemble that when I
looks roughly the same i guess most
people in like bread egg one so i had
the same but I mean it was looks you
know me like long sleeves as such yeah
like you're saying though it just looks
so much more alive like I mean to love
one detail like look at the the pots and
pans and like hanging from there and
like you know it's real sad is that none
of these people are on their phone you
know I mean like they don't know what to
do without them just before just that
this miserable this girl is like the
store clerk is like yeah everyone got
their stuff today we can wrap up at noon
because there's only about a dozen
people in this town I can get home and
send a telegram to my wife whatever you
that's great Mac that's the solitude of
red dead right like right here cool yeah
like who's this does that yeah I don't
know will be interesting we should see
if like look he's definitely a high
collar that's like it looks like a heavy
coat see if like this sort of look
matches up with one of the seven people
at the end oh yeah for sure right here
that guy looks like a guy wouldn't want
holding a shock no he looks like you
look super drunk man freaking vultures I
didn't see the dog I watching the
vultures rip apart what it seems to be a
another dog thats dark yeah these those
buildings don't look like definitely
don't like western
those look almost like one with one on
the right is like war war torn or like
yeah used to be on fire uh on the left
yeah on the left there that's a right
yeah but definitely its immediate know
he's it's smoking yeah i think was on
fire you can even say maybe for the ones
on the right a little bit I don't know
they look a little damage but yeah about
this this reminds me there will be blood
yeah that's like oil rigs and other
collegiate windmills but I know those
are oil rigs look in the background yeah
it's just like this I don't know I have
to go there again but this kind of looks
like I think it's called like plain view
ranch in red dead in the first red dead
named after Daniel plane oh yeah yeah
yeah it was like kind of like almost
when you're headed to Mexico it was kind
of green and there was like oil rigs
through out there but I mean these are
usually we don't see enough I don't
think that's those look like oil rigs
right like the fire with the I'm spewing
out dude again I feel like this game
like you said to Jake like the Steve
just like see that's so sick this is a
good shot there's I don't know there
seems to be a lot of like this is much
desert right I mean excited these guys
my water on the ground like it reminds
me of like like their rainy season West
almost obviously ya like like winter
like snow or like water melting so the
natural assumption is obviously these
are the seven from the cub the teaser
image the they're all wearing masks ya
think so it's obviously so it's so it's
a gang like it's they're criminals you
would assume why else would they cover
their face it's not like they're law but
and then right here this looks like Utah
like mesas and [ __ ] with the Rockies
with the Rockies there that would make
sense these kind of like plateaus it was
like I think they're even going towards
the Rockies I'm saying it like you start
in the desert and you like or heading up
north by again you know I mean do you
think that
you'll be playing as those seven
characters or do you think you're just
playing this one well it was my like
wish I like obviously like it's pretty
ambitious you know like GTA 5 goes
between michael trevor and franklin but
if you can go between seven people i
think that would be too much to keep
track of but Rockstar usually knows what
they're doing yeah this look this like
Northern Lights yeah I know you're like
let's start you know it could also be
the magnificent magnificent seven way of
like assembling your gang as the story
progresses yeah like that is very much a
trope of like finding your gang your
crew yeah and then hidden note that is
what rock star likes do that to play off
tropes right so that would actually be
pretty cool I think they could do
something cool if you were like or like
man even-even like maybe like SciQuest
right you pick one of your crew members
your gang members who is a specialist in
some manner mm-hmm like your explosive
expert you need him to crack the safe
yeah and then for the bigger picture
stuff you use all seven and then you'd
orchestrate some kind of like you know
plans I'm some tactic or something like
that kind of like a GTA hi sort of thing
play I'd we want to see that again and
I'll see anything else are we seeing
them you know the other thing i want to
say he's like you know what the dialogue
was uh yeah you ride and don't look back
or something yeah it gave me the vibe
during the shot where it was panning
around him with a fire he looks me what
you would assume to be the main
character he looked really grizzly
mm-hmm there's not this side of his face
briefly maybe that's potentially him
getting on his horse at his ranch like
maybe this is a caretaker of a ranch and
he gets you know yeah ranch burned to
the ground ranch burns with a gray these
are like plants on fire right here this
guy seems this guy seems like risley
added like out of shape you know what I
didn't like this is not his style and
he's being told or you know trained to
basically do something like that I was
my initial like opinion well do you
remember there was the leak of the map
right right while ago do you remember
what the map was of I was a while ago I
for you
so long all right um do you see
everything we wanted to see I'm switch
back to yeah we can probably expect to
read dead okay hon the first one oh cool
I think we'll be seeing a lot more yeah
that's just probably too sir I'm gonna
check that through the twitch again and
then see if anybody else had some yeah
maybe someone else sasa 310 to yuma the
game i forgot about that movie that is a
freaking awesome movie how does not
submit its Christian Bale right yeah
Russell Crowe and uh forget his name but
the villain of that movie 10 to Yuma
yeah he um he's he's kind of like who's
the medic and private and private ryan
who i also think is in that movie um
he's been fosters out here talking about
yeah i forget other movies he's been in
like if you seen like alpha dogs Oh a
long time ago remember that movie I
don't know like he's when those guys
it's like kind of like a like a b-level
actor but he kills it in Israel yeah and
he didn't act like he was a very
sinister man anyways cool yeah he's in
the warcraft movie as well to lone
survivor that's exciting yeah yeah think
it's what I wanted cuz I'm curious like
oh no maybe you can look up the sea that
leaked map cuz i wonder if that like
sure actually has any have this guy died
I shot him you tried to shoot his hat
off without asking for me excuse me sir
yeah that was cool you know um I don't
know I you know it's it's a teaser I
call that more of a teaser than anything
yeah um it was just passed it to user
you know like yeah I think of a teaser
as like one shot two maybe three even
[ __ ] for maybe that's teaser it's live
almost yeah but that was that was a tad
sparse it looks I mean from that chair
there like that I know they said like
this red dead is gonna be very
atmospheric red
redemption to and just watching that
shadows like yeah this is this looks
very atmospheric like it looks like
there's gonna be a lot of like quiet so
so based on the leak map apparently
which is just yeah like northeast of red
dead redemption original map I'm
grateful interior area so well yeah
maybe can you full screen it will wait
and maybe Mary can do that actually let
me find a better ok so this digital it's
on digital trends but so people are
saying there was a lack of railroads on
the on this map but obviously we saw a
train with next to the Bison so that
makes sense will be great plains and
this is supposedly just so the southwest
tip of this map is supposedly the
northeast of red dead redemption one
where the Great Plains are start to get
snowing up here so that makes sense but
you say well you could be right it
sounds like part of the map and so it
starts yeah it becomes like getting
toward the mound obviously it's not to
scale but okay I mean are those I
imagine the geographically speaking
those are strikes like environments
right like those are very cut and dry
snow forest desert marsh whoa that says
new Bourdeaux right here that's the name
of the map and mafia 30 what if this is
just the Mafia 3 me it's not but what it
the way it is it is shut the hell up are
we looking at the Mafia 3 map no but I
mean this is the red lever energy that's
owned by you and wa damn it Mike people
have the wrong no I didn't lay it's a
[ __ ] it's remember being this but
your Creek no it's not this is Rona
Ridge but there's new Bourdeaux and a
bayou no I meant like I don't remember
this being the leaked map that's my
forget though oh so when I was a while
ago
anyways ya see what what is this article
talking about this is Digital Trends
saying like perhaps the strangest bit of
information revealed in the leak map
power is that red Demeter's to may
actually be a prequel source the 2k
games mafia series well where are you
it's digital trends in touch it's it's a
real out like it's a trust outlet don't
blame me for pulling us up I don't know
who else to blind who shop well I mean
they're both under the take too not that
that matters but I I just didn't like if
take to look yet could you tie a red bed
into Mafia three they'd be like go first
you say yeah go for personal like
nothing against like I like mafia three
but like I can't imagine rockstar ever
doing something supposedly that was one
of the reasons why uh what's his name
from who directed iron man John Lavra
Jon Favreau do didn't do like the third
movie was because he was getting sick
tired of Marvel telling them how to time
all and all guys and together they
wanted to do his own thing surprise me
I was
John Marshall gentlemen it's quite the
crew right there it's time we must go
why what's happening seth has managed to
get himself inside mm-hmm but we can't
leave it too long or they will soon
realize how very curious he is and
remove him from the premises or